alors vous le voyez ici il fait de plus
en plus chaud le printemps en fait tu
deviens un peu l'été ça tombe bien parce
que hier soir il y avait une soirée la
fraîcheur la fraîcheur c'est une dj qui
nous a fait bouger les murs du palais
jacques-coeur un monument ici ah bon
ambiance discothèque au palais
jacques-coeur une dj la fraîcheur et une
seule danseuse véronique lemonnier
devant un public assis dans une salle
qui ressemble plus à un musée qui a une
boîte de nuit là on était à l'opposé
même de ce qui fait notre culture et
donc c'était vraiment un défi de se dire
bon comment est ce qu'on va pouvoir
représenter trop retour transmettre
l'essence de notre culture dans un
format qui en est à l'extrême opposé sur
scène la relation entre le dj qui sont
publiques qui est dévoilé une relation
intime hypnotisante
une façon aussi de défendre la culture
club souvent méprisé et réprimés nous
sommes pas ni des voyous ni des
terroristes
il n'y a pas de raison que notre culture
ne soit pas mis au même niveau que l'art
visuel dans les musées que le cinéma que
le théâtre que que la danse classique
contemporaine
on est une culture nous apportons dollar
de l'art et des sensations désormais
retrouvé par le public en se laissant
porter par la musique la danse aux
sociétés excellente c'est en fait on ces
conditions se projeter au niveau de la
danseuse passionnant et la danseuse très
envoûtant pour le coup par contre la
frustration c'est d'être assis ça m'a
donné envie de danser mais ça va me
motiver d'aller lancé ailleurs dans ces
ailleurs ce sera possible en discothèque
à partir du 9 juillet alors maintenant
on va parler musique de la belle musique
des belles personnes hier on a fait une
rencontre absolument fantastique elle
s'appelle silly boy blue et c'était
c'était la folie
[Musique]
silly boy blue elle a gagné les inouïe
il y a deux ans elle revient aujourd'hui
à bourges
pleine d'émotion et envie de retrouver
la scène berruyères j'espère que ça leur
plaît puisque c'est mon premier album
que je joue sur scène et que je défends
sur scène donc c'est un peu défendre mon
bébé du coup c'est beaucoup d'émotion et
beaucoup de peurs et beaucoup de hat
en même temps je pense
[Musique]
déjà trois jours de printemps de bourges
et toujours pas de musique dans les bars
alors moi je vous propose d'aller
découvrir une terrasse une terrasse où
il ya enfin m
[Musique]
tél
prendre un peu de hauteur être dans les
nuages pour avoir de la musique dans la
ville cetoula ben du printemps de
bourges
cette année les bars sont muets la faute
à une réglementation tatillonne
c'est pas possible en fait on avait des
concerts de calais qui sont déprogrammés
au fur et à mesure la préfecture
n'autorise pas les concerts comme ça
dans les bars une seule exception
l'incontournable et son riff apparemment
il ya qu un concert ici j'étais au
courant mais il y accueille ici qu'il ya
des concerts ce soir on est dans le café
où il avait pas forcément de concerts
donc donc là et ça change et puis c'est
bien et c'est de la bonne musique ça met
de bonne humeur il ya des petits quiz
je m'attendais à moi je pensais même pas
qu alors autant fait pour moi le plus
attendu cette année c'est il n'y avait
rien qu en me les concerts organisés les
voeux du bien d'avoir un peu de musique
dans les bars comme avant on va dire
le renouveau est là déjà l'année
dernière ça va bouger du tout donc que
ça bouge un petit peu c'est déjà pas mal
on peut pas tout avoir break une édition
où il est difficile de faire la fête
dans la ville
aucun attroupement sur la voie publique
est autorisée mais pourquoi un seul bar
est ouvert à la musique
cette fa l'établissement alors
aujourd'hui on peut effectivement en
faire à l'intérieur à l'extérieur on a
la possibilité nous parce que la
terrasse et en privé
on n'est pas seul domaine une exception
culturelle à oublier pour 2022 pour que
bouge retrouve son festival
c'est déjà la fin de cette page sur le
printemps de bourges et je vous propose
simplement de revenir un peu en images
sur les gros concerts d hier est le
principal c'était pomme
je compare surtout et
tu es là bas
on croit
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]